In the modern
era, Batman is one of the most popular
superheroes
to ever exist in the history of DC Comics,
and I would go so far as to argue he's
more popular than Superman.
What's so funny about this
is Batman is not supposed to exist
because there was a time when DC Comics
was going to cancel his comic book line
and kill him off forever.
So when Batman first
came onto the scene in 1939,
his stories were dark.
His early comics saw him killing villains
with poison gas, hanging mental patients
from the bat wing, watching on while
villains burned to death, and even showing
the Joker
assassinating a political official.
Sure, they were morally questionable acts,
but his no kill
rule had not been established
by this point, and the general argument
was that the villains had it coming
anyway.
But all of this changed in the mid
to late 1950s.
The reason for this was due to a pseudo
psychologist named Frederic Wertham,
who published a book in 1954
called Seduction of the Innocent,
arguing the comic books were corrupting
America's youth, Wertham’s
book drew the attention of both
the American People and Casey Kefauver,
a senator from Tennessee,
who saw the book as a rallying cry.
As a result of the general public's
reaction,
as well as his own political aspirations,
Casey brought Wertham before the Senate
Subcommittee on Juvenile Delinquency
and Wertham’s testimony
nearly led to Congress passing legislation
that would have severely restricted
what could be published
within a comic book.
But despite the testimonies
of Comic Creators, Publishers
and other Psychologists who saw Wertham’s
book as an example of cherry picking data,
something had to be done.
So the comic industry chose to regulate
itself,
establishing the Comics Code Authority.
The ins and outs of the Comics
Code are outside the scope of this video,
but any comic that did not contain
the Comics Code Seal of Approval
would not be sold,
and among the various rules of the Comics
Code was the rule
that vigilantism could not be glorified
and depictions of extreme violence
couldn't be shown.
But what was Batman,
if not a comic book character glorifying
violence and using extreme tactics?
So to ensure that Batman comics could be
sold,
DC was forced to tone his character down.
His dark and hyper violent ways
were replaced with goofy moments
like the Rainbow and Zebra Batman suits
in Detective Comics 241 and 275,
respectively, the sword fight between
Batman and Superman in World's Finest 143
and the story of Batman
wearing a jester hat
and punching the side of a building
in a World’s Finest 109.
Being such a stark difference
from the stories that so many had grown up
with meant that Batman's audience
had begun to dwindle.
Fans were angry and they were betrayed
in that the antithesis
to Superman's Boy Scout mentality
had been reduced to a goof.
But with their hands tied by the comics
code, what was DC Comics supposed to do?
The Adam West Batman
show was actually the saving grace
the DC Comics needed.
Originally intended
to be a juvenile adventure show.
The television rights for Batman shifted
from CBS to ABC, and then eventually FOX,
who hired William Dozier
to produce the series,
but after reading several of the existing
Batman stories under the rules
of the Comics Code,
Dozier decided to make the series campy,
focusing more on nonsensical
slapstick humor.
But much like during the height
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe, viewers
who had never read a Batman comic
in their life
saw themselves flocking to local stores
to pick up the newest issue
of the Caped Crusader,
and for a time, sales skyrocketed.
In fact, between 1966 and 1968
when the show aired, Batman's comics
went from selling 400,000 issues
per month to almost 900,000.
And it made perfect sense.
The 1960s
were a socially chaotic time in America.
Society saw some of the highest highs
with NASA's moon landing and Beatlemania,
but they also saw the lowest lows
with the Civil Rights Movement
and JFK’s assassination.
These, combined with the looming threat
of mutually assured destruction
during the Cold War, meant
that the American People wanted an escape.
Adam West, Burt Ward, Caesar Romero:
they all provided exactly that.
But as the show went off the air in 1968,
sales of Batman started to collapse,
falling
to 355,000 in 1969.
But by this point, the Comics
Code Authority, which had been this
almost omnipresent entity
looming over both creators and fans alike,
had now become virtually toothless due
to stories like Green Lantern Green Arrow
Snowboards Don't Fly, and Spider-Man’s
The Green Goblin Reborn, both of which
dealt with the issue of drugs, completely
ignoring the rules of the Comics Code.
This matters because in 1971, Dennis
O'Neil and Neal Adams began
their legendary Batman run.
While most people credit Neal and Adams
for taking Batman back
to the old Bob Kane Bill Finger
darker stories in his earlier comics,
the significance of their run
is much bigger than that.
Unlike the comedic and campy
Batman of the 1950’s and 60’s
who came out on top
because of circumstance, Dennis O'Neil
and Neal Adams had transformed Batman
into a kind of James Bond character.
The stories shifted their focus,
presenting a more human and fallible
superhero that relied more on
his detective, spy and fighting abilities.
The more fallible side was shown and that
he could be taken by surprise and beaten.
His detective skills were showcased
through disguises and sleuth tactics
while his human side came in as empathy
towards any and all victims of crime.
Villains like Ra’s Al Ghul were introduced
as a looming threat,
while Neal and Adams stayed away
from Batman's traditional rogue's gallery
with the exception of stories like Joker's
Five Way Revenge and Half An Evil
which saw the return of Two-Face
after almost 17 years;
and all of these stories
flew in the face of the Comics Code,
helping to shatter
what little influence it had left.
But despite the return to classic Batman
storytelling, the sales of his comics
continue to slip, dropping
from 200,000 issues
per month in 1973 to 89000 in 1985.
This was compounded
by the overall DC Comics landscape
in that the advent of the Multiverse
in The Flash of Two Worlds
and the DC Implosion of 1978
meant that for the average comic reader,
entering the DC landscape
meant having to decipher the main universe
from the varying alternate realities,
figuring out where Batman resided
within the existing continuity,
as well as sifting
through the massive catalog of DC Comics.
In effect, DC was almost impossible
to access if you were new to comic books.
And so in an effort to reconcile
their multiverse and clean slate
their landscape, in 1985
DC launched Crisis on Infinite Earths.
The purpose behind the event
was to eliminate the Multiverse
and then relaunch with a single universe
known as New Earth,
where the various characters of the DC
landscape would receive updated
origins and new Number 1’s,
giving new readers a fresh place to start,
but because of his low sales,
Batman's future was up in the air.
On one hand,
he'd been a staple of the DC Universe
for over three decades,
but on the other: his sales were low,
there were no film or TV prospects
on the horizon to boost interest
and Crisis on Infinite Earths presented
the best opportunity to kill him off
and cancel his comics.
Now, it was around this time
the Frank Miller was working on
both Daredevil
and the Wolverine
mini series at Marvel Comics,
and while Marvel had its own
share of problems with Jim Shooter
as the Editor In Chief, Miller
caught the attention of Jenette Kahn,
the President of DC, and Dick Giordano,
the Managing Editor for the entire Batman
line.
In truth,
Miller had no interest in writing Batman,
and had actually wanted to focus on Ronin,
a six issue mini series
with a cyberpunk feel, but to Jenette
and Giordano, a Batman story
written in the vein of Frank Miller's
Daredevil was an absolute no brainer.
And so the three of them struck a deal:
If Miller was willing to write a Batman
comic, he'd have free reign on Ronin,
and for Miller, it was solid.
Pulling off a Batman story
that could return the character
to the height of his popularity would
solidify his name in the halls of Comicdom
Forever, and the icing on the cake
was complete creative
freedom on a series of his own making,
as opposed to the creative limitations
imposed by Shooter Marvel.
The other side of this was that if
Miller story failed, Batman was done.
Now, a lot of discussion
surrounding the development of The Dark
Knight Returns centers on its influence
from Dirty Harry
and Frank Miller building on the old Bob
Kane, Bill Finger and Dennis O'Neill
and Neal Adams runs,
but a lesser known influence for the story
came from Alan Moore's Watchmen.
Much of the same way that Watchmen
was rife with political messages
and themes, illustrating how superheroism
can consume, change and break people,
The bleakness of Watchmen is mirrored
in The Dark Knight Returns,
in that Gotham and the world overall
look and feel like a very dark place.
Batman has long since retired criminals
have overrun
the city and corruption has taken hold.
The Joker returns and then basically kills
himself, leading to a massive manhunt
for Batman because everybody believes
that he's the one that killed the Joker.
and the story culminates
in one of the most significant moments
in DC Comics history:
Batman fighting Superman.
Now, for the non comic reader,
this is simply the first
and what has become a mainstay battle
between DC's most popular heroes,
but for the person
who'd been reading comics for decades,
this was game changing.
Something to understand is that the
relationship between Batman and Superman
dates back to 1952 with Superman 76,
The Mightiest Team In The World.
Prior to this,
they were just two characters
published by the same comic book company,
but crossing over in such a way now
meant that they shared a single universe.
Gotham City was here.
Metropolis was over there.
And so in the decades that followed,
the team ups between both these heroes
had become so popular that DC launched
a series called World's Finest,
and while it initially contained
separate stories involving these guys,
it evolved to showcase Batman, Superman
in occasionally Robin
teaming up to fight some foe.
The point that I'm making here
is that whether through some kind of
shared conflict or something
as simple as a cookout,
Batman and Superman were viewed
as friends, but on a larger scale
Superman was untouchable.
From the original Jerry Siegel and Joe
Shuster stories to the Mort Weisinger
era of the 1950s, Superman was DC's
flagship, an unstoppable force
standing for Truth, Justice
and the American Way.
He was a hero
who stood up for the common man.
On the other hand, Batman was just a guy,
and a well-placed bullet
from an unsuspecting location
would mean the end of Bruce Wayne,
and so for longtime readers to crack open
a comic book and find that Superman
had become a government stooge
and that decades of friendship
had rotted away, leading to a fight
among Titans with Batman
triumphant was unheard of.
And they loved it.
By 1987, Batman sales had skyrocketed,
jumping to 193,000 per month.
Frank Miller followed this story
up with Batman Year One, a retelling
of Bruce Wayne's origin in the Post-Crisis
Era and the Batman explosion was on.
Within 3 years,
Batman had overtaken Superman in sales,
DC had expanded its lineup to include
comics like Tales of the Dark Night,
and Tim
Burton was directing a Batman film.
And so while I believe
that the current work of writers in DC
Comics cannot be ignored,
especially considering Scott Snyder's
landmark Batman
run with the New 52 in 2011,
I think it's equally important
to stand up and say: Had it
not been for Dennis O'Neill, Neal Adams
and Frank Miller, Batman
as we know him, simply wouldn't exist.
With that being said, guys
we're going to bring this video to an end.
If you're interested in getting
into Batman as a comic book character,
make sure you click this link
and it'll take you to our Batman playlist.